England is a nation which has had a significant impact on and in fact has played
a significant role in shaping human civilization for hundreds of years.
And today in this video,
we're going to take a look at that history and explore just what England is,
who his people are,
and how it became the world's changing nation that it is today.
So to start,
you have to know exactly what England is.
And I'm guessing if you clicked on this video,
you've probably heard of England before and that's great.
But a lot of people don't know the difference between England and Britain or
England and the United Kingdom and things like that.
So really quickly here,
here's the island that we call a Great Britain.
The term great isn't about ego,
it's about geography.
Here is England.
It's important to understand Scotland here and whales here are also British.
This whole thing is Britain.
So while all English or British,
not all British or English,
it confusion typically comes from the fact that today these three countries are
all United into one single country.
The United Kingdom,
which also includes Northern Ireland and use to include the rest of Ireland for
reasons that we'll get into today.
But because England is a seat of the union is seat of the kingdom,
the term British is often mistakenly only applied it to England.
So with that out of the way,
let's focus on that part of the island,
which we call England and let's go back a little over 2000 years.
At this time England was inhabited by various Celtic tribes,
not Celtic,
Celtic compared to the Mediterranean nations of Europe around at a time such as
the Romans.
The people here were a primitive though,
not as primitive as you would imagine.
The Celtic tribal societies of early England were fairly complex agricultural
societies.
They were in contact with the European mainland and on the bright side of this
trade made its way to and from pre Roman England,
but I'm a dark side.
They were at times invaded by tribes from the European mainland.
Though they all spoke a similar language and fall,
a similar religion,
which was a predecessor of modern Celtic languages such as Welsh for example.
They were not United society as a people.
Accordingly,
of course,
they wage war with each other during those wars.
They would build defensive structure as much like the one shown here called
maiden castle dating back long before the Romans even arrived on the island.
The religion practiced here with similar to much of Northwestern Europe at the
time.
In fact,
the Romans noted that the religion that they practice in England was very
similar to the one which they practice and gall also known as modern France.
It was a pagan religion,
but what's very interesting about it to most people is the druidism that was
practiced here and and the rest of Britain and Ireland as well as the druids
were unique to the British isles.
The jurors were a very interesting group of people.
They were religious authorities of course,
but they weren't just priest.
They were also politically involved as they were doctors.
They were judges,
they were historians,
they were advisors,
things like that.
They were a very much a group of elite and Iron Age England and their opinion
had considerable impact on the early societies here.
Much of what we know about the societies of this time comes to us from the
Romans and their records of the island and we see evidence of the impacts that
the jury has had on our society.
When the Romans do you come to the island that they call for Tanya.
Now it's fair to have mixed opinions on the religion that was practiced here and
throughout rest of the British isles called simply Celtic paganism.
There was some human sacrifice involved,
which is to most of us today,
pretty abhorrent.
The Romans back then didn't like it either.
They were appalled by it.
They discussed how horrendous it was that the Celts would do such a thing during
their gladiator fights and we've actually found some evidence of this human
sacrifice in the United Kingdom and Ireland.
This is a picture of a decently preserved corpse of an individual who was a part
of these practices from these times.
I believe this individual is from Ireland.
On the upside though,
as I've explained before,
the Pagan Celtic beliefs stuck around in various ways to influence us today.
The most notable example is perhaps Halloween at Celtic night of Shaaban,
which was Christianized and then became modernize to the holiday that we know
today there was no writing in a society and in fact the druids when confronted
with writing,
we're fine without it.
They claim that writing things down was bad for your memory.
So a lot of what we know about England at this time comes to us from
archeological finds or as I said,
the accounts of the Romans and it isn't and it is when the Romans invade Britain
that we really get to understand the world here.
At the time in 55 BC,
Julius Caesar invaded Britain and again in 54 BC,
but he was unsuccessful both times essentially getting no territory.
Part of the justification he had four invading island was that the people of
this region had assisted the Gauls against Rome due to their economic
relationship with him.
They're both cal state Los related to each other.
They trade it and things like that.
Remember also that I said that the British tribes were not isolated from the
rest of Europe like one might think they were,
but the true age of Roman Britain comes about 90 years later and 43 [inaudible]
40,000 Roman soldiers set sail from the province of the gall to invade the
island.
Now,
there were a number of obvious benefits to be obtained from invading and
capitulating for Tanya trade and resources and the expansion of the empire and
all that,
but a huge motivation here was that the emperor at the time wanted to improve
his image.
Emperor Claudius came to become emperor and he was quite justifiably insecure.
He was seen as kind of weak and even moronic by his peers and by the population.
He thought that if he could go to Britain and conquer it and affect what we do,
what Julius Caesar did not do,
he would bolster his image quite significantly.
And so he ordered the operation and put his brother in law and command of it.
The Roman soldiers were admittedly frightened by this prospect before they left.
The records tell us that the morale was kind of low.
Britain at this time was the edge of the unknown,
so they were obviously very scared.
They were concerned that the island,
Harvard,
ferocious,
ferocious savages and demons and such things.
Morale though did change and the Romans set sail for Britain lending and Modern
Day Kent.
Unfortunately for the native Britons though when the Roman is land and they made
a mistake,
the Britains actually caught wind of the fear among the Romans and assume that
there would be a mutiny before the Romans could land.
So one of the most powerful tribes on the island and the kind of Aillani did not
make a proper move to defend the shore.
They simply assume the invasion will dissolve before it arrived,
but it did not.
And the Romans lended and establish a fort and even a triumphal arch eventually
in such things,
and then they pressed into the rest of the island.
Now there was obviously a good deal of conflict as the Romans pressed in to the
rest of her.
Tanya,
there were at times a number of revolts amongst occupied tribes,
but a significant amount of tribes,
about 11 in fact,
actually surrender to the Romans during this time before conflict even emerged.
Why?
Well,
the Roman military machine,
as historians optim refer to it,
was simply too powerful.
The Romans were susceptible to guerrilla warfare,
of course,
but out on the open field to tribes like those in Britain at the time did not
have much of a chance to bolster this image of being a powerful and unstoppable
invasion force from Claudius actually comes to visit Britain.
He enters on an elephant,
a beast which the people of this region had obviously never seen before.
They were astonished.
Roman occupation sets in and Tanya modern dating England again becomes a
province at defining moment in early English history.
Not everyone is so satisfied with being occupied.
However,
Boudica a woman of the ice,
any tribe in particular was not satisfied.
Boudica was the wife of a very important tribal figure who maintain an alliance
with the Romans.
However,
after her husband's death,
the Romans turned on them.
She was beaten and her two daughters who were raped and incident that she did
not easily forget around 60 Aidy Boudica gathered forces from multiple British
tribes,
primarily the Ice Sonny and avant Hays as well,
some others,
and led a revolt against the Romans.
The revolt was not a minor incident.
Her forces would cause extreme chaos in the province that she killed thousands
of inhabitants and burned down three cities including London,
indium,
if that name sounds familiar to you,
the situation was becoming so extreme that the emperor at the time,
Nero considered withdrawing from Britain entirely.
However,
Boudica was eventually defeated.
She was never captured by the Romans.
Rather it was likely that she committed suicide who avoid capitulation following
this incident,
Britannia was firmly Roman.
The Romans would hold on to this province until four ten eight d.
Now talking about history so far back,
that might not seem like such a long time,
but keep in mind that was 350 years.
The United States today for comparison is only 241 years old,
so it was a decent span of time.
So after that fairly turbulent time period of conflict with the picks of the
north and other rebellions and disorder and such things,
Rome starts to become weakened and it's homeland.
It simply can't afford to spare troops or supplies to defend this and provinces
like per Tanya.
So when Rome starts to become weakened and the province starts to face threats
from the picks and the dramatic tribe is threatening Britain,
the emperor or notorious,
basically it tells them that they're on their own,
which was shocking to the British people.
And the Roman empire just altogether fell 66 years later though the Romans had
technically left Britain.
It's important to consider what the Romans had left behind at this point.
Roads and infrastructure,
cities like London,
Manchester and New York and of course Christianity,
which will play a major role in English history.
And following the fall of Roman empire,
we begin to see a rise from this reveled,
the beginning of what will be eventually called England but not quite yet
following fort to.
And it's not like as soon as the Roman military left that the British society is
suddenly reverted back to his pre Roman state was of course still Roman Britain.
They were,
Socrates still held his power.
The structure was still roaming the Britains,
we're still Christians,
a lot more was still spoken,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
What had happened was that the Britains were just suddenly given self rule
mostly against their wishes,
but it was what they were stuck with.
They pleaded multiple times for the Romans had come back following for 10 but
now with no such thing happening,
they set up their own military and defense modeled of course off rums.
So even though the Roman Empire is a gone,
these people are still identifying as Romans,
Romans to sidle structure,
as I said,
is still in place.
And that will continue even after the Roman empire has fallen,
despite their efforts to defend themselves.
They're not very successful picks from Scotland,
Irish from Ireland and other raters tear apart the country.
So the people of former Roman Britain come up with a very Roman solution to the
issue,
hire mercenaries to deal with it.
And that's what they do.
They hire a group of very effective mercenaries that had already been fighting
on the side of the Romans as mercenaries from northern Germany known as the
Anglo Saxons.
Three ships of these people are sent over to deal with the picks and deal with
them.
They do indeed.
The picks are deep.
They're badly to feed and driven back into modern day Scotland as tribute for
the service to Britain's give the sex in some land in modern day Kent,
which leads to many more sections coming over to settled in Atlanta.
Thousands of them,
in fact,
and it's not just warrior mercenaries coming over anymore,
it's women and children and that means they're saying,
adding onto this,
it's entirely likely that the Anglo Saxons and other north dramatic peoples had
already been living on the island for a while before all these incidents.
Unfortunately though,
after the picks are dealt with the Britains discover that the Saxons aren't very
good neighbors,
they're pagans,
they're considerably different.
They don't see eye to eye on a number of things and eventually the whole thing
backfires on the Britain's and the Saxons invade them.
Conflict erupts and the British are led by a leader named Ambroziak or really
honest or Romano Britain considered to be one of the last Romans,
and so the two sides go to war over what will become England eventually after a
sustained war.
The two sites meet at the battle of Mons bad economists around the year 500
probably near the modern city of bath.
This is a very important battle.
It's here that the Britains finally defeat the Saxons and secure their existence
against total domination.
Following this battle,
the sections are left with the east of England where the develop around 30
kingdoms to the West.
Though the Britains actually keep on living.
Their land is named after the Saxon word for foreigner.
Whales is during this conflict also that we begin to hear legends of King Arthur
and in fact it's said that a figure known as Arthur was responsible for the
British picture you at the battle of Mons bad economists and also for the long
period of peace with the Saxons,
which followed.
How much of this legend is true?
Well,
what really happened in detail is pretty unclear.
Obviously these major events and territorial changes in battles and such things
really did happen,
but it probably wasn't as much of a solidifying,
clean cut and the vision between Britain's in Saxons as tales tend to tell.
In fact,
probably a lot of Britain's just assimilated into Saks and culture as they were
invaded and more sex and immigrated to the new land.
King Arthur May have been real.
He may represent an actual figure.
Again though the truth remains unfortunately unclear,
but historians are emphasizing that following this conflict inside you,
it wasn't as much of as Saxon invasion as it was a Saxon migration as evidenced
in fact of Saxenda the Britains living together in circumstance certain
circumstances and just eventually the Britons who did not go to Wales just kind
of adapted to the dominant sacks and culture and language and traditions and
things like that.
The angles in the Saxons were just two of the North's dramatic people to settle
England.
They were also primarily joined by the Jews and some DNA evidence suggested the
free agents from Modern Day Holland to join them as well.
These tribes followed very similar religions and very likely spoke very similar
languages and in fact they had little difficulty communicating with each other
through time.
These Germanic tribes would cease to think of themselves as different from each
other and reach a point of integration.
At which point they would simply prefer to call themselves the Anglo Saxons or
in their Anglo Saxon language Anglican.
Why not sex ish or sex link considering the great importance of this accident
tribe?
Well,
again,
the gradual integration made the distinction less important.
Interesting to note though,
even today in many Celtic languages,
the name for England is still based off to sacs and people.
Shoshana,
for example,
in modern Irish,
the 400 or so years following the Roman Empire is fall is a period marked by
very large migrations of people across the Europe in general and England
continued to absorb immigrants from northern Germania,
Anglo Saxon England through the 500 so the 880 it was ruled by scores of
kingdoms and a very turbulent and admittedly confusing landscape and in fact
it's not just confusing to us today.
There's reports of foreigners from the mainland being confused by it.
The names of some kingdoms in fact are lost to history,
but the major ones included ones such as Kent,
Wessex,
Sussex Mircea,
and North Umbria.
Throughout the seventh century,
the Anglo Saxon people began to convert to Christianity.
The remnants of this conversion lasts to this day,
though the Roman empire had fallen to pagan invaders.
That his sentence of these pagans across Europe did in fact end up obviously
converting to Christianity and pressures from the mainland whales and also
Ireland,
which had already been converted to Christianity.
He led to the Anglo Saxons adopting the religion as well and through
Christianity they connected themselves to the larger European picture in a
critical time when post Roman Europe was forming the spike conflicts and lack of
political unity among the early English,
this was a time of economic stability and prosperity.
It was a time period in which Anglo Saxon language,
religion,
culture,
society,
and such things could begin to take root.
Unfortunately at the same time that the Anglo sex and we were taking root in
England,
another force not far from their island was beginning to take flight.
Our forest,
which due to geography,
the English would bear the full brunt up and that's for us would permanently
altered the course of English development.
This forced developing in modern day Denmark,
Sweden and Norway.
We know today as the vikings,
to elaborate a little bit here,
the word Viking more correctly refers not to the Norse people,
but to the Norris Raiders and explorers who wrecked havoc on Europe for over 250
years.
A period known as the Viking Age and England would be forever changed by it and
in fact the viking age would begin and England off the coast of North Umbria on
an island known as Lindisfarne not,
we've already talked about the vikings on this channel before,
so I won't go too into depth on their origins if you're interested in that.
I have videos on my channel already.
I made the mistake of breaking them into like five separate videos,
but you know,
it's the same content essentially.
So these vikings arrive out of Scandinavia to,
as I said,
the island of Lindisfarne.
Lindisfarne was a small island home to an Abbey of monks were living there.
It was not a well defended area and that was actually kind of intentional.
As I've said,
the politics in England at this time were very turbulent and unstable.
You had kings and kingdoms being the victims of and the propagators of these
plots and conflicts as seemed to continue without cessation.
So churches essentially just kind of one of the be in isolation away from all
that.
Now the attack on Lindisfarne in which these vikings just showed up and
essentially slaughtered or enslaved all of these defenses.
Monks was not the first Viking raid on the British isles and not even really the
first raid technically on England,
but it was the first specifically recorded major incident is recorded in what
are called the English,
sex and chronicles and that's why it marks the beginning of the Viking age.
For the next 60 years,
England will be plagued by viking raids.
Now it's not as if to English.
Kings did nothing about this.
Eventually they did wise up and prepare defenses against the vikings,
which were effective.
In fact,
many of Viking Raiders just kind of gave up on England and started going to
weaker Scotland and Ireland,
but the lack of political unity in England prevented and United response against
the Viking raids in the beginning.
No,
I said 60 years.
I don't mean to mislead you to think that after these cc years that things got
better.
On the contrary,
they got worse.
The Viking say,
instead of reading England,
let's just go and take it over,
and so on the year eight 65 a few viking leaders actually assemble an army to go
and do this.
It's not clear how large the army was.
It might've been about a thousand warriors.
It might've been over a thousand.
It might have been even less than a thousand so not a magnificently large army.
Keep in mind there was no single Norse nation at the time to raise such an army.
It was more like a coalition of a bunch of different viking groups coming
together out of a mutual interest who would in all likelihood not associate much
after England had been conquered.
It was a small army,
but it was a considerably devastating one.
So here's England at the time.
As you can see,
there are fewer kingdoms here than was the case and the seventh century.
It's mostly dominated by this time by Mercia,
North Umbria and west ex with the Celts to the west and the north and some other
Anglo Saxon Kingdoms in the east here and the vikings land in the territory of
one of these smaller eastern sex and kingdoms,
east Anglia.
The East Anglian's didn't really put up much of a fight at first.
They sort of just surrendered and like let the Vikings pass through their land.
In [inaudible] 66 they moved to attack north Umbria.
They took the city of York and the North Umbria is a sanctuary surrender to and
the vikings put a puppet king on the Northumbrian throne.
He's saying Leah later rejects is Viking domination and stands against them of
their crushed and our leader.
King Edmond was killed.
So by now as you can see,
the vikings have made very significant progress into England with actually very
little conflict.
Now they moved to invade the Kingdom of mercy,
mercy ans put up quite a fight and they call on assistance from the Kingdom of
Wessex to do so.
In the year eight 70 a viking named bags like brings reinforcements called a
great summer army with a Viking army now strength and they begin to pillage
England and moved toward the Kingdom of Wessex,
the King of West six at this time as a king named Ethel Red and he leads an army
along with his younger brother Alfred only 22 at the time to take on the
vikings.
They were at first,
not very successful,
but eventually the image at what is remembered as the battle of Ashdown
elsewhere.
Red and Alfred split their forces into to the vikings began to advance across
the field,
but Essel red insisted on praying before advancing to meet them.
Alfred,
on the other hand,
felt that there was no time for prayer and he charged toward the vikings with
his half of the army and with the help of his brother who later did join him.
He was victorious and the Vikings retreated back to the land which they had
conquered England referred to as the Dane law shown here.
Ethel actually dies at the same year and Alfred rises to become king.
The Vikings though defeated at this battle.
We're definitely not dumb and they continue to threaten Mercia in Wessex.
Alfred at first paid them off,
but eventually in the year eight 78 he engaged them in battle again where he was
again victorious.
It was now that the vikings were kind of falling back,
they withdrew from mercy of back to the Dane Law and it was clear that England
would remain accordingly.
Alfred gets two very important titles place to him and history.
The first is the great.
He's only one of two monarchs in English history to be called the great.
The second is that he goes from being called King of the West Saxons,
which is west six to king of the Anglo Saxons.
This idea of Anglo Saxon unity begins to take root here and it continues on with
his successors.
In the year nine 10 alphas son took it the even greater limits.
He conquered the Viking shown here in East Anglia and the vikings here in Mercia
as well and began moving northward eventually Capturing York.
Now as you can see,
Edward had control of a considerable amount of modern England.
He ruled over many of the formally divided Anglo Saxons and this is where we
begin to see the title King of England feed truly accurately used Edward's son.
Athelstan continues the expansion of this kingdom and his neighbors don't really
like it.
In fact,
the Scottish and Irish kingdoms of the day get kind of concerned about this
rising English power in the unite with the Vikings temporarily and take on SLS
and at the battle of Bruno Uber in nine 37 which the English one thus preventing
the progress from being fractured for the moment anyway,
and nine 78 the vikings returned under the leadership of Harold Bluetooth and
the King of England known promptly as EFA.
Rather,
the unready was unfit to face in order to even maintain England's existence.
He was forced to pay tribute to them for 20 years,
which greatly crippled the English economy.
And the year 1001 Ethel red married the daughter of a viking king,
the king of Norway,
but in 1002 he foolishly or the massacre of north settlers in his territory who
were politically more aligned with the rising nation of Denmark.
Then just more the ambiguous term,
Norse,
which led to another 10 year conflict with the Danish Vikings,
Ethel red floods in Norway,
where he subsequently died in 10 14 the same year as painful period.
The king of the Danish.
Now the throne of England was up in the air and Knute the of Spain defeated
Ethel Red Sun Edmond and claim the throne for himself becoming King of England.
Intense 16 Knute wasn't done there.
Two years later,
he came to the throne of Denmark and in 10 28 it's sort of Norway as well.
Thus founding the North Sea Empire,
also known as the Anglo Scandinavian Empire.
They'll Knute subsequently became the second and only other king in English
history to be known as the great.
His Empire did not last pass his death and 10 35 in fact,
it essentially was over with his last breath.
Knute sons did succeed him in England and his line continued until 10 42 when an
Anglo Saxon Edward the confessor took the throne.
Edward ruled until 10 66 were after he died without an air,
which quite obviously was going to cost and problems to solve.
This Harold Godwinson,
the richest man in England and Anglo sex and to whom he likely did,
actually the throne succeeded him.
In fact,
he hastily Kieron himself the day of Edwards funeral.
Regardless though Godwinson his reign was doomed from the start and many people
of the day believed it,
especially as Holly's comments had passed by England's during this time,
which was seen as an obvious omen.
That same year,
England was invaded by Harold Hardrada,
King of Norway,
who had the intention of restoring the North Sea Empire.
The Viking forces met the Anglo Saxons at the battle of Stamford Bridge where
they were brutally defeated in her drawer was killed by an arrow.
The better of the two Harolds had.
One is death and the failure of the Vikings Conquest and marks the end of the
Viking age.
The Vikings did not have an insignificant impact on England to though in fact
their influence affected English history permanently.
They contributed significantly to the English language.
They set up a number of settlements in the British isles,
including the city of Dublin,
which would become the capital of Ireland.
Their culture in general presence shaped English,
sex in England.
It's a nation that it would become and they even laid the seeds for England's
next invader,
the Normans.
It was not even a month after Harold Godwinson his victory over the vikings,
that intense 66 William the conqueror,
the Duke of Normandy,
invaded England.
In fact,
it was only three days later.
Part of the justification for this was that William actually had a claim to the
English throne and he was related to Harold's predecessor,
Edward and William,
and in fact,
much of Europe believed that the throne ought to have gone to him.
William was very confident in his ability to conquer England.
Tales were later told that his mother had a dream of great tree extending over
Normandy in England the night that he was conceived.
Now here is normally today a part of France,
but it's important to remember Normandy was culturally and linguistically in
such very similar to France,
but the Normans themselves,
including William or in French Guiana.
We're the descendants of vikings who had carved out that territory about 150
years early in simply integrated themselves into French society.
In fact,
the name normity is related to Northmen,
I.
E.
The Vikings.
So William Invades England with around 10,000 or so men,
and within a few weeks he meets Harold Godwinson,
who commanded maybe around 8,000 men.
At the battle of Hastings,
Harold and William were extremely eager to meet each other.
In fact,
reports tell that William actually put his armor on backwards at first rush to
meet him.
The battle lasted for most of the day and the Normans outgunned with having more
archers and calvary and likely outnumbered the Anglo Saxons.
The Anglo Saxons were defeated at this battle.
Godwinson was like they killed toward the end of it and soon thereafter,
hope of victory against the Normans was lost.
William the conqueror now ruled one of the most powerful and stable kingdoms in
Europe of the day.
Hastings went down as one of the most significant battles in English history.
Major changes fall.
This battle never again would an Anglo Saxon rural England,
the Anglo Saxon aristocracy to had largely been dispossessed and replaced with
Norman Aristocrats and will sax in English was now the language of the
peasantry.
The ruling elites spoke Norman French and would actually continue to for some
time,
but Norman,
French and English would not remain separate.
They would merge.
In fact,
modern English has a heavier influence from Norman French than the Anglo Saxon.
Old English giving us a plethora of words.
Many English sacks and nobles simply left a country and move to Scandinavia or
Scotland or Ireland,
including some of Harold Godwinson,
his family who moved to Ireland.
The Normans moved into capitulate the Anglo Saxons by asserting their dominance.
They built churches and castles,
including London Tower.
They documented the entire country of revealing to us great detail about the
societal structure of England.
A thousand years ago.
They gradually eliminated slavery in even at the time reporting,
perhaps 10% of the population was formerly enslaved but rebellion Brood and the
North William face in English,
sex and rebellion,
which was assisted by the Danish,
which he brutally suppressed.
The Normans would face other rebellions too as well.
It's an invasion from France,
but their hold over England will remain firm.
William died the 9th of September in the year 10 87 his successors when they
weren't busy trying to hold onto their reign,
we continue to rule England and eventually moved into Scotland and invaded Wales
and Ireland.
William successors were not quite as successful as he was,
so civil war broke out over successions.
The monarchy would become considerably unstable and following two invasions from
Scotland,
England enters into a period call to the NR where in King Henry,
the first nephew,
Stephan and his daughter fought for control just certain large because Henry de
first son had unfortunately died unexpectedly.
This period which lasted 17 years is remembered for it's savage violence and
bloodshed.
Henry's daughter had divorced the holy Roman emperor and had married Jeffery to
count of volunteers you,
which becomes a very detail in 10 33 she has a son with account whom she named
Henry.
Henry was destined to succeed his father,
but as his mother,
Matilda had great hopes that he would one day become king of England as well.
After a considerable amount of conflict with both sides coming close to victory
and then an ability switching sides accordingly each time.
The civil war eventually ends in 1152 was Steven becoming king.
His rule was uneasy as if that wasn't obvious following almost 20 years of civil
war,
but his succession was also unclear.
And furthermore,
his reign included England.
Losing lands is Scottish and wash invaders.
Despite these troubles,
Steven reigned until his death and 1154 two years after the NRK officially ends.
By this time,
Henry Matilda's son was now the ruler of all you and much of western France,
and he had married Eleanor of Aquitaine.
Unfortunately for Steve and his son used this,
a died earlier in the year 1153 leaving him without a successor.
He reached an agreement with Henry and Henry would succeed him and there would
be peace in England regarding the succession.
Henry was coronated on the 25th of October becoming Henry the second and
founding the Plantagenet dynasty,
which would rule over the college event,
empire encompassing lands,
what would stretch from northern England to the pier knees.
So once again,
England had more French speaking rule us from friends.
In fact,
Henry only ever spoke very poor English,
French and Latin.
We're all that.
The ruler of England of the day needed Henry.
The second was known for his great temper.
He was power hungry,
ambitious,
energetic and impulsive.
To his benefit.
He used these traces of cure power from the barons back to the monarchy and
allowed him to expand his empire in the Scotland,
Wales,
Brittany in Ireland.
But to his degradation,
he would cause much of his own family to turn on him and he would have a number
of shocking incidents such as a death of Thomas Beckett,
the Archbishop of Canterbury Baguette get in the king had been feuding for years
and following a transgression.
It's recorded that the king said in front of his men something along the lines
of what miserable drones and traders have a nourished and Brock and my household
to have let their Lord be treated with such shameful contempt by a low born
cleric.
Henry's nights over hearing these words,
took them literally and the assassinated Beckett's soon after an event,
which would ruin Henry's image across Europe.
Now,
obviously Henry had no intention of actually killing the Archbishop of
Canterbury,
but he could not control his anger and his men.
Miss took him 1189 Henry would be succeeded by his third son,
Richard.
The first it becomes B set of Richard that he possessed a cool dileo or the
heart of a lion because of his grace access and battle.
Most notably during the third crusade where he fought against a lot hadeen the
Saltin of Egypt and Syria,
but also of course in defending his father from rebellion in his youth and also
in the battlefields of France defending his territory is there,
despite being king of England,
rich would spend perhaps as little as six months of his reign.
Actually in England.
In fact,
he didn't have a whole lot of interest in England itself.
He preferred to see it as a territory which supported his much larger European
empire.
Richard would die in 1199 from an error wound which became infected.
What?
Fighting in France.
He was succeeded by his younger brother,
John,
who was less of a popular the ruler.
In fact,
he isn't remembered as a very good ruler at all in English history.
He first rebelled against his father,
Henry,
while he was still king and then later against his brother Richard,
while he was king.
Failing.
Of course,
false times.
John was deeply concerned about being the youngest son of the royal family,
but when placed in positions of power such as an Ireland,
he displayed greed and power hungriness.
Despite this,
he still became king.
It's during John's reign that a tale of Robin Hood is a place,
you know,
like government so bad that a thief is actually praised.
John committed quite a few mistakes during his reign.
He fought multiple losing wars in effect,
Lost Normandy to France and the Contravent empire really began to collapse with
John.
According lead John,
we'll place heavy taxes on the lower class is to pay for these wars and would
seize land from an ability in the church to augment his power.
He would even go so far as to rape the daughters of his noble subjects and
personally murder a contender to to throw in while he had him in prison.
The nobles aside that they can't just sit by and let this happen in the church
was pretty unhappy too.
So eventually a band of these Nobel supported by the church gathers and army and
rebels against the king and they march on London and the Archbishop of
Canterbury drafts a treaty or a new rule book that was settled to dispute the
Magna Carta and English,
the Great Charter.
It contains 63 new laws,
which the king was obligated to follow up with regard to the church and the
treatment of his barons.
Not with so much focus on the common people just yet,
but it was a start towards limiting the power of the government.
King John signed it on the 15th of June 12th 15 now John was essentially forced
to sign it.
He had no intention of actually following through with it and he really didn't.
The pope a node it and in fact civil war would eventually break out between John
and the barons and John Wick continued to nine of legitimacy of it until his
death in 1217 even though the principles laid out by the Magna Carta had a rough
start,
it remains a significant document as being the first time in English history.
That's certain ideals were proposed.
It puts forth the idea of rule of law that the decisions of a nation should be
made with great focus on the benefit of the nation,
not as much the ruling elite.
It proposes that the king may be above the laws of men,
but not the laws of God.
The king cannot be murderous and tyrannical without being reprimanded.
It created a system where many of the kings decisions has it be cross checked
with a noble as of England as system which would lead to the modern parliament.
Quite obviously,
many of these principles are central to England to this day,
John Son Henry the third,
we also fight over the legitimacy of the Magna Carta and we would actually call
together the first equivalent of a parliament.
Henry would be succeeded by his son Edward,
the first along shanks or long lake cause he was a considerably tall and
intimidating individual.
And 1272 this is the king from the famous movie Braveheart,
and I won't go incredibly into detail about that in this video because I've
already done a video on the true story of that already.
But Edward did indeed invade Scotland during his reign earning him the nickname,
the hammer up to Scott's.
But he did more than that too.
As prince,
he took part in the ninth crusade.
I'm gonna fight him,
fight in the conflicts surrounding the Magna Carta and such.
At a time on his coronation at Westminster Abbey,
which was built by his father,
Edward was crowned and he declared that he would only a door in the crown once
again,
when all the lands lost by his father,
we're his,
he was intent on dominating the British isles as king.
He put down rebellions in Wales,
reformed English law and reaffirm the power of the monarchy while at the same
time sending a parliaments permanents parliament gave him a route to taxes.
Subjects provide funding for his various war is on and off the British isles,
but problems regarding the power of the monarchy was with great regard to this
would continue even after his rule.
He ordered the expulsion of the Jews from the country of ban,
which lasted until the 17th century.
Edward would have a very prolonged and costly war in Scotland dealing with
figures such as William Wallace,
but a number of other Scottish nobe wasn't leaders as well.
Even though prior to this period,
Scotland,
England lived in relative peace.
During this war though,
Edward procured the stone of Schoon,
the stone on which all Scottish king has had thus far been coronate and he took
it to England.
Who owns it to the state,
though it is now captain Scotland,
though he maintained his kingdom with a strong hand is weaker son Edward.
The second lacked his strength.
His son Edward,
who is only one of the 15 children that he had,
would ultimately lose the lands that his father had,
one in Scotland to Robert the Bruce and would be a generally weak leader.
He was a very obvious homosexual which angered the barons of this day and likely
contributed to his great difficulties with his wife who would betray him with
Roger Mortimer of Wales.
He neglected his cane lead duties.
He had the unfortunate coincidence of being a king during bad weather,
I.
E.
A two year fem in which killed off 10% of being less population and he was just
eventually to posed in 1327 Mortimer and his wife Isabella ruled until Edward,
the second son Edward killed Mortimer and imprisons,
his mother becoming Edward.
The third Edward the third's early rain consisted of war with Scotland and what?
She had a decent amount of success but eventually agreed to a truce with the
Scottish part of the reason for the war,
which Edward the third found himself in with the Scottish was a looming threat
which England was right in the middle of an alliance between Scotland and
France,
perhaps middle medieval England's two greatest enemies with fears of a full on
invasion of England from France and with France interfering with English trade
and what the rest of the continent.
Edward knew that he would have to take action against France and you'd have to
do it soon.
To counter the Franco Scottish alliance known as the alt alliance,
Edward would ally himself with other European nations notably with Portugal in
the alliance with Portugal and as a matter of fact would endear as one of the
longest lasting alliances and world history.
That's not all though as the king of France will leap to six took the Duchy of
Aquitaine.
Edward would not solely just resist this invasion on his former territory.
He would be so bold as to claim the throne of France for himself.
Edward was in fact related to the French monarchy.
Phillipe to sixth was his uncle,
but he did not have that much of a legitimate claim to the French throne.
Edward was technically the closest living relative to trials,
the fourth,
the last king from the house of the Copay,
but Charles,
his instructions for the nobility to choose the next thing in France and they
chose Phillipe 60 marking the beginning of the house of Valois and French.
Notably Edwards actions were very obviously a response more to the political
situation of the day,
but Edward would still,
regardless press is rights as king and would indeed invade France.
Even changing his royal standard to include both lions of England and the flare
to leaves of France as shown here,
the war for the throne of France would not be an insignificant one.
In fact,
it would last for over a hundred years and thus historians have creatively named
it the hundred years war.
Two important points regarding the name Hundred Years War though.
The first is that it wasn't a hundred years exactly.
It was 116 years.
The second it wasn't just one long endless war.
It was more like four wars with a series of side wars,
I suppose you could say involved in this 116 years dispute.
The four main wars where the Edwardian war,
1337 to 1360 the Caroline worth or a teen 69 to 1389 the Len Castro and war 1415
to 1420 and the second Lancastrian war 1422 1453 in 1340 Edward and his son
Edward,
who would be known as the black prince,
invade France to not only defend the English possessions,
possessions that England had in France,
but of course to claim the crown of France with England visiting France.
Scotland moved in and retook much of their former territory,
but their success in war against England during this war would not last forever.
The English and the French met at the bowel of Cressey on August 26 1346 the
battle of Cressey,
it was a disaster for the French forces,
the English with Louis,
perhaps around 200 men,
the French with Louis,
perhaps 6,000 obviously with this defeat,
the French king was outraged,
but how did this catastrophic defeat happened?
Edward was fighting war differently for much of the European warfare leading up
to this valve for hundreds of years.
The horseman was the master of the battlefield against Archer and infantry men.
They were difficult to defeat Edward prepared for this though he had his men dig
holes in the ground which would cause a horse of the trip.
He would put up stakes to deter or kill anymore horsemen and crucially he
employed the English Longbow.
The English Longbow,
which was likely first invented in Wales,
had a greater strength range and speed and the crossbows,
which the French and their Genevieve's mercenaries were using.
They were in truth a deciding factor of this battle leading to a brutal French
to even though they outnumbered English forces.
Edward was also not fighting a stereotypical war either rather than having a
series of battles as had been in a case in warfare leading up to this point,
again,
he preferred to simply skirmish the French relentlessly.
Not long after this battle,
the black death ravage as much of Europe,
including England and France.
The you're seeing a pestis bacteria traveling across Europe from Central Asia
through hitching a ride on pests would kill a victim with an a matter of days.
It began in 1348 and lasted until 1349 but it claimed the lives of 6 million
English alone,
half of the population at the time,
France to lost perhaps half of its population.
It would return in the 1360 he's again killing millions regardless of the
circumstances of the war,
would continue.
Phillipe to six died in 1350 and was succeeded by his son John the second on
September,
1913 56 the English and French would meet at the battle of Poitier where again
the French would suffer a devastating defeat.
Not only will they lose thousands to again minimal English losses,
but their king was captured and was later ransom in 1360 the English and French
sign the Treaty of Breton,
neat,
which heavily favor the English allowing them to keep all the land which they
had one and on the French side we'll at least at end of the conflict.
This piece would only last nine years though and the hundred years war would
start once again and even during this peace conflict and Brittany,
which involved both England and France would be occurring.
I mentioned some new developments and how this war was being fought that were
very innovative and revolutionary for the time,
but longbows,
we're not the only innovation.
Artillery had a significant role in this war and gunpowder was making its debut,
albeit awkwardly.
Beyond that though,
societies were changing,
even though this was a war concerning the power of monarchs and ability,
nationalistic tendencies were evolving in France and England.
People felt a sense of duty not only to their king,
but also to their nation.
This attitude was quite certainly influenced by the introduction of standing
armies.
Prior to this,
armies would be raised by the king and noblemen temporarily for his,
but because of the longevity of this conflict,
the English and French felt unnecessary to have a more permanent and discipline
fighting force and the monarchs of these nations revise things like their
taxation methods to support this.
In 1369 the war was back on propagated by the French.
This time on their Charles the fifth hence,
it became known as the Caroline wore.
The pope pleaded with the compounds to find peace,
but the church was preoccupied and was unable to truly convinced it to to cease
hostilities.
Edward's son Edward,
the black prince would die in 1376 and Edward a third in 1377 Edward the third
would therefore be succeeded by his grandson who became Richard the second and
1377 Richard was only 10 years old at a time,
however,
and therefore regency under John of gaunt,
Richard's uncle wasn't stated in 1381 following the stresses of the black death
and the stresses of the taxes he used to pay for the war.
The English peasantry revolted led by Walt Tyler of Kent.
The revolt itself was not very successful and was over within half a year,
but it showed the socio economic strain on England during this age.
Three years later,
and the 1384 war with Scotland began again and a king was forced to raise taxes
making,
making king Richard even more unpopular.
Meanwhile,
the French carved back into many other territories which have been lost in the
first phase of the Hundred Years War.
Bringing the English to accept the truce.
In 1389 the French had won the second phase of the war and peace would continue
until 1415 Richard the second was dethroned in 1399 and replaced with John of
God's son,
Henry the fourth Henry.
The fourth was interestingly the first king since Harold Godwinson,
whose mother tongue was English,
not French,
and very significantly,
he was the first king of the Lancastrian branch of the house of Plant Agilent.
He would rule until 1413 when he was succeeded by his son,
Henry the fifth who would play a major role in the hundred years war.
He too would assert his claim over this French thrown and after making alliance
with the Burgundians in 1415 Henry would invade Normandy and very unfortunately
for the French,
they're King Charles's six was insane.
He was essentially unable to rule and this caused a great divide between the
French nobility about his succession leading to a bit of civil war.
And this is a very crucial time.
On October the 25th of that same year,
the battle of Agincourt took place and this was a third grade French military
disaster,
English tactics and technology succeeded again and the English loss,
perhaps 600 men while the French laws very likely over 8,000 Henry presses into
France and in fact finally in a sense secures the French throne.
Henry is declared to be following the treaty of Troy as the air of Charles is
six the king of France.
To secure this further,
he marries the king's daughter Catherine,
but then something unexpected happens.
Henry dies young from dysentery and 1422 only two months before Charles is six
days now Henry's air was his son also named Henry,
but the French did not recognize the young Henry as the air.
They instead named their king's son Charles,
who would be Charles,
his seventh king.
And so of course war continues.
It would've been very interesting to have seen what would have happened if Henry
the fifth had not died young and would have gone on to become king of France.
But of course,
that's not what happened with war.
Back on though a new hero or rather heroin would rise to the scene this time on
the side of the French,
a young girl from the lower classes named John Doc or an English Joan of arc.
Joan had claimed to have had a vision from saints telling her that it was her
duty to drive out the English from France and she tried to tell the King of
France the king was not interested at first until she made an accurate
prediction regarding an upcoming battle.
After this,
that cane decided listen,
and she claimed that she had to lead to the French army to relieve the city of
Orly all from a siege.
She did so and she was victorious and was subsequently made a commander of the
French forces.
Now in this time period,
the French would have been reluctant to accept a farm girl as a commander,
but France was running out of options at this point and she seemed to be
succeeding not long into the war.
When she was only 19 though the Burgundians captured her and sold her to the
English and the English found her guilty of heresy and burnt her out the stake.
The English had finally captured Joan of arc,
but her affect was irreversible and the French.
We're now winning the war.
The war technically ends in 1453 at the battle Castillo where England lost all
land in modern France except for Kallai and France securities victory.
Even though officially speaking,
the two nations would remain at war with each other for 20 more years or so and
England would continue to claim the crown of France for many years to come.
Following this war,
England would begin to enter the early modern era.
The social,
technological,
and governmental and such aspects of English society have been changing and
would continue to change following the hundred years war,
but another conflict had been brewing throughout the hundred years war.
However,
internal conflict in England,
one which would surface following the end of the war and the end of the reign of
Henry does six who was considered a poor king and exacerbated by his wife
Margaret.
Yvonne you the wars of the roses as it came to be called.
The wars of the roses were a series of a civil conflicts of law for the control
of the [inaudible] between the two houses of the Plantagenet dynasty.
The Lancastrians represented by a red rose and the York is represented by a
white rose.
The conflict was not so cut and dry as it's often portrayed entails at the time,
especially those from Shakespeare,
and even though it lasted for 30 years,
it wasn't a brutal agonizing war on the part of the English people in the year
1485 the conflict comes to an end as Henry the seven slaves,
Richard the third at the battle of Bosworth field of battle which only claimed
the lives of 2000 or so men,
but mark the end of the English Middle Ages for good Henry,
this seven to land cash room with questionable heritage,
thus merges the two houses of York and Lancaster and to the house of tutor by
marrying the daughter of Henry,
the fourth Elizabeth,
which he represents with a white and red rose as shown here,
and England moves on into a new age,
though now the ruler of renaissance England,
Henry to seven still had to clean up from the Middle Ages.
The wars of the roses had fractured England's government and he struggled to
hold onto his crown quite wisely.
Henry pursued a peaceful foreign policy trying to improve ties with both
Scotland and France.
Henry to seventh died on April 21st,
1509 he was succeeded by his 17 year old son who became Henry the eighth thereby
securing the continuation of the Tudor Dynasty.
Henry would be a very busy king though in the eyes of many of the day,
not the best one.
His older brother Arthur had died seven years prior to leaving the kingly duties
to him.
In fact,
Henry would simply Mary his widow,
Katherine of Aragon,
daughter of the king and queen of Spain.
Catherine would bear him two songs,
but both would be stillborns.
The inability to produce an heir would trouble Henry very much concerned with
securing his succession and would not only trouble Henry,
but what cause a good amount of trouble for England in years to come.
In the meantime,
Henry would engage in conflict with the French largely for personal glory as
these wars that she is relatively little.
At the same time,
Scotland would invade England,
which would be another relatively pointless for for which Henry would take the
credit and winning.
Even though Katherine had managed the matter while Henry wasn't friends,
Catherine was still failing to produce a male heir.
Though she had produced a daughter,
Mary Mary would be the only one of seven of Catherine's children who would live
to adulthood.
This deeply concerned Henry of female air in itself was a concern for a 16th
century nation,
let alone one for a nation which had just come out of the wars of the roses.
Henry was determined to have a male heirs,
so determined in fact that he would make an incredibly bold move.
He was essentially left with three options.
He could legitimize the one of his illegitimate sons,
which would have been problematic.
He could have attempted to have a grandson to inherit the throne,
which would have also been problematic,
or he could divorce his and marry a new one.
He chose the third option in 1527 but the pope did not approve.
So how does Henry respond?
He leaves the church altogether and starts his own church,
not while the English reformation,
as it's called,
was incredibly audacious.
It did occur at the same time as the much larger Protestant reformation.
Though the English reformation was quite obviously less about religion and more
about politics.
Henry was very serious about this or in the rest of England to convert to his
religion and in fact executing many who actively resisted this schism would
change English history permanently,
throwing them into religious disagreement between Europeans for centuries.
Henry would then Mary Anne Boleyn who would give birth to a daughter,
Elizabeth,
and also very unfortunately a stillborn son out to center,
respond to this,
not very maturely.
He was convinced that he was cursed and he accused MLN of witchcraft and had her
executed would then Mary Jane Seymour who would finally give him a son,
Edward.
Unfortunately,
Lo Jane Seymour would die from postpartum complications soon after Henry would
marry three more times after her death producing only Mary Elizabeth and his son
Edward,
who would succeed him as Edward,
the six and 1547 and cruel irony though Edward would die before the age of 16
from tuberculosis leaving only Mary and Elizabeth to inherit the throne.
Mary.
After doing a way with lady Jane Gray became queen in 1553 there was an
interesting twist to this though Mary was a Catholic and was quite adamant about
returning England to Catholicism,
so after the English had been bullied and face death for resisting Anglicanism,
now Mary turn it around and bullied and executed.
Anglicans refused to convert back to Catholicism.
This was not the time to be openly pious and Mary Burns nearly 300 Protestants
alive.
As a result,
she was given a nickname at bloody Mary.
Mary died in 1558 and the English did not miss her.
Despite attempts to secure a Catholic on the throne,
including Philip,
her husband,
and King of Spain,
she would be succeeded by her Protestant house.
Sister Elizabeth Elizabeth would rule for nearly 50 years ushering in a golden
age and English history known as the Elizabethan era.
One of Elizabeth's first acts was of course,
return England to Protestantism.
This led to the pope declaring her it legitimate and a heretic.
Yet Elizabeth quite wisely was not as aggressive consulting Protestantism as her
predecessors have been.
She was more tolerant of Catholics and accordingly,
she maintained a decent amount of peace in England between a different religious
groups.
At the day.
Elizabeth never married and had no children earning her.
The title,
the Virgin Queen later on the English would name a North American colony after
her Virginia.
Why she chose to never marry is unknown.
She claimed that her husband was England and her children were the English
people.
Although it's very likely linked to the political instability that a marriage
might've caused,
especially for a queen,
but she did in fact have many suitors and she fell in love with a man named
Robert Dudley.
Under Elizabeth's reign,
English renaissance culture would flourish and most notable figure of this time
being William Shakespeare considered perhaps one of the greatest writers in
human history.
Just because Elizabeth was more tolerant towards English Catholics is not mean
that foreign Catholic nations were tolerant towards her and she would be forced
to deal with the plus and conflicts of other major Catholic powers of days such
as France and Spain.
One of her first moves regarding this political and religious situation was to
spread Protestantism in Scotland there by attempting to break the Franco
Scottish alliance,
knowing that France could use Scotland as an ally in a potential war as it had
done many times throughout history.
Part of the reason for this threat came from Mary,
the Queen of the Scots,
who had also been the queen of France for only a year,
and furthermore,
the great granddaughter of Henry [inaudible],
seventh of England Catholic Europe recognized marry a Catholic as the rifle
ruler of England and she married Henry Stewart and English Catholic with a
client,
had the English throne as well.
Quite naturally this concern,
it was a beds greatly and she would spend years feuding with her.
Eventually marry was actually asked by the Scottish nobility and she fled to
England for protection.
Elizabeth would not have it though when she imprisons marry for 18 and a half
years until finally she had her executed for clotting to assassinator.
Elizabeth would attempt to avoid conflict throughout her reign.
Now she did send forces to assist Dutch Protestants against the Catholic Spanish
rulers while Spain.
Accordingly support of the Catholic Irish against the English meddling like this
would lead to the Anglo Spanish war in 1585 the situation was exacerbated in
1587 when Mary,
the queen of Scots was executed.
This outrage,
King Philip of Spain,
Mary had left in her will that Phillip would inherit her claim to the English
throne should she be killed and Phillip vowed to put a Catholic monarch on the
English throne and in fact received support from the pope to overthrow her.
He began preparing a fleet.
However,
it was sabotaged by Sir Francis Drake.
A year later the Spanish we repair and set sail for England,
but English tactics as well as unfavorable weather successfully repelled
Spanish.
Our motto while under the command of Charles Howard and again Francis Drake
while addressing her Forrest,
is in preparation for potential Spanish invasion on the island.
Elizabeth is quoted as saying,
my loving people.
We have been persuaded by some that are careful of our safety to take heed how
we commit ourselves to armed multitudes for fear of treachery.
But I assure you I do not desire to live to distrust my faithful and loving
people.
I know I have the body but have a weak and feeble woman,
but I have the heart and stomach of a king and of a King of England too,
and I think fell scoring that Parma or Spain or any prints of Europe should dare
to innovate the borders of my room.
Elizabeth had defended the Protestant religion in England and she had defended
it from foreign rule as well.
She led England during a time in which great figures such as Shakespeare,
Francis Bacon,
and Francis Drake were alive and by successfully challenging Spanish power.
She paved the way for England to become a greater power,
thereby opening a road to the Americas.
She died in 1603 as the last tutor monarch.
She would be succeeded by King James at first who was also king of Scotland.
Being a son of Mary,
queen of Scots,
despite being the son of an ardent Catholic,
James had converted to Protestantism and was intent on keeping England that way.
We'll pick up a one happens with James and the next video.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
we should have checked out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.